Hello? Yes, this is he.
Him? Me?
Right.
The first time.
I'll be right there.
Mitchell, That was it. That was the
call. I'm going in.
Due to budget cuts, my position as
middle school music teacher has been
eliminated. So I've been working as a
high school sub.
Cha-ching. I never know when I'll be
summoned to swoop into action.
I'm kind of like Batman, but except for
a bat signal, I get a phone call.
Yeah, you found the one difference.
I did my best to cram for my lecture on
the Revolutionary War, but all those
names and dates, it's all so dry.
Where's the drama?
Good morrow. Oh, boy.
Well, what is all this strange garb you
adorn? Are you trappers from the
Canadian provinces?
Are you here to sell your beavers?
Who are you?
The £0.64 question.
I crossed the Delaware during the
Revolutionary War.
I spent a brutal winter in Valley
Forge. Who am I?
I have no idea.
I swear. I don't know who this man is.
I'm George Washington.
Of course.
Our syllabus says we're supposed to
cover Native Americans on the eve of
colonization.
Yes, Native Americans.
Indians. A majestic, peaceful people
who lived off the land and cried when
they saw litter.
The textbook says many tribes were often
at war with allegiances shifting all of
the shifting.
All the time.
So were the Indians friends with the
colonists or not?
Oh, yes, I know one Indian who was
friends with a construction worker,
biker and traffic cop.
Nothing. Seriously?
Nothing. Okay. Your parents are going
to love that joke.
The Native Americans and the settlers
had two completely different ideas of
land ownership.
Eventually, these differences would
lead to war.
Oh.
Look. Goosebumps.
Okay. Yes.
Class dismissed.
We did it. Thank you so much for
stepping in.
Oh, and I promise tomorrow I will do my
best to be more prepared tomorrow.
Why won't Mrs. Hurley be back?
Well, I don't want to be indelicate, but
the good news is, is I might be your
permanent teacher.
I don't want you to be my permanent
teacher.
Oh, what, you'd rather have a raging
alcoholic?
Listen to me. I have worked nonstop to
build the perfect academic record, and
I'm not going to let you screw it up
now. I have an AP test in 160 days, and
I need to ace it.
Can you get me there or not?
I can rally like the brave men of the
Alamo.
You do realize that all the men of the
Alamo died.
They all died.
Set! Hike!
Oh, hey. You're going the wrong way.
That's the wrong way.
No, wait. I'm sorry.
You're right.
Excuse me, Principal Brown.
Yikes. And, you know, most subs just
play a movie. All right?
Do something different, guys.
Listen, I can't be your history teacher.
Those kids work so hard, and they
deserve someone who knows the material
and can inspire them.
So if you say so.
Hey, I was wondering, what kind of play
was that you were running? Was that
supposed to be a slant?
A freshman coach quit. I'm just a
glorified babysitter.
Well, your receiver needs to learn to
run his routes, or the quarterback's
never going to be able to hit him. I
played in college.
Oh, okay. Hey, Tyler, you need to learn
to run your routes.
What routes?
Yeah, What routes?
Well, you got to line up here.
Take three steps.
One, two, three.
Plant right open, left, 45 degrees up
the field. Okay, why don't we try it
again? Try it again.
Ten. Put some zip on the ball.
18.
Hut, Hut! Hike!
Hit him. Better.
Better. Good job.
Circle back up.
All right. Anyway, thank you for the
opportunity. Hey. Hey.
How would you like to take over this
team?
Oh, well, that's an interesting offer.
How much does it pay? Nothing.
Are you firm on that?
Yeah, but there's a gym teacher position
available. It's all yours if you.
Coach, can I wear shorts?
Yeah.
And you get a whistle, too?
Oh, I always get a whistle when I wear
shorts. I humbly accept your offer.
Huddle up, boys.
Let's go. Hustle.
Do you know what hustle means?
Ten.